[Musique]
une nouvelle cassette bon richard voilà
ce qu'on va faire
il nous faut un échantillon de voix vous
allez dire dans ce téléphone
il y à une bombe dans centennial park
vous avez 30 minutes mais chars vous
êtes devenu un héros national
merci monsieur mais j'ai fait mon
travail c'est tout on s'intéresse
toujours à celui qui a trouvé la bombe
comme celui qui a trouvé le cadavre du
haut elle correspond au profil du poseur
de bandes solitaire un homme blanc
frustré qui rêve d'être dans la police
qui a envie de devenir un héros au pubis
vous êtes un suspect vous ne parlez pas
je parle dit le jeu ne parle pas c'est
le moyen de vous disculper
dites-le il y à une pompe dans
centennial park vous avez trente minutes
dit chercher à leur plaire élevé dans le
respect de l'autorité l'autorité va vous
bouffer tout cru
bombe dans son génial parc vous avez
trempé du porno quoi ses accusateurs
sont deux des forces les plus puissantes
du monde
le gouvernement des états unis et les
médias je cherche vraiment à vous aider
ou aussi je fais partie des forces de
l'ordre
il y à une pompe dans centennial park
vous avez 30 minutes
les charges où elle est innocent c'est
un héros
il y à une pompe dans centennial park
vous avez 30 minutes
encore une fois un peu plus fort
j'expose les faits vous avez bousiller
la vie de cet homme
il ya une bombe dans centennial pas vous
avez trente minutes de la suite
l'office a sauvé la vie de ces gens
[Musique]
il ya une bombe dans centennial park
vous avez trente minutes j'avais posé
une bombe dans centaine yal parc vous
avez 30 minutes
je ne sais pas comment je peux protéger
y a pas plus coupables que votre client
paul vous exécutez
vous êtes prêts à vous battre